subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell make sure
to uh is there somewhere is there like a
movie account page
where can they follow you or the movie
so they can be notified about all this
stuff that's the most
important question you've asked the
entire time i can't believe we didn't
say it yet
you can watch the movie on august 28th
at this is the year dot film
this is the year dot film i think
everything we were like going over
everyone's gonna be like
we watch this damn thing what are we
missing
i can't think of anything
ladies and gentlemen of the reject
nation we have a very special guest with
us today
famously hailed from the pits
[Laughter]
method in red and i believe a toaster
strudel's commercial
there was a very good toaster commercial
it's
[Music]
and uh i believe you were on a disney
channel show that's right uh
that sort of that's so raven what you're
thinking about
that's a great show very good one day
you will get
somewhere in life david henry is with us
today what are we watching today david
i've reunited
uh with selena gomez and we've reunited
to bring
a feel-good movie to quarantine
world because i feel like people need to
feel good right now so uh she executive
produced and i wrote and directed this
movie called this is the year which
stars greg sulkin jeff garland
wow lorenzo henry jake shortly lorenzo
henry as in your brother lorenzo my
brother lorenzo henry that handsome
devil from fear the walking dead oh
name dropped title drops all around here
i haven't seen this yet i'm stoked for
you to see it this is a
a trailer for the premier event this is
gonna be an interesting reaction where i
will not be self-conscious about feeling
like i have to like this the entire time
i'm gonna be watching and david's just
gonna be looking at me is this trailer
working
is this doing it actually this is a new
uh finalized cut i got sent this morning
so i actually haven't seen this oh
really
hi guys i'm reuniting with my friend and
big brother david henry oh
snap oh wizards reunion i'm excited to
announce the first ever
live virtual film premiere for our new
movie this is the year
which premieres august 28th that i know
lorenzo's
[Music]
most premieres are only for a very small
select group of people but
not this one we want all of you to watch
it with us
wow dude oh this film's going to be here
you'll not only get to watch this is the
year with us you'll also participate in
a live q a with me and selena
then the cast will join for a q a
performance
from lovely the band if we'd be by
tonight we could be live q a okay
we just need some wheels bro yeah leave
that to me sweet
and you just got to help me commit zoe
to come with us it's a road trip with
friends just like in the movies what are
we leaving
oh yeah i forgot to mention um it's all
moderated by charlie and dixie demilio
hey everyone we are oh my god those are
famous tick tock people
let's have some fun holy moly
ghetto lorenzo i was kind of confused
which girl he was into but all right
this movie is all about change a theme
that couldn't be more relevant in 2020
just by purchasing a ticket you've
contributed to the plus one covid 19
relief fund oh that's great because i
like david this whole time live
digital premiere event on august 28th at
this is the year dot film
while you'll watch the movie with us
wow wow it looks looks great
that was exciting man thank you dude
that was exciting
so let's only talk about wizards of
waverly places
[Laughter]
what's the reunion david
i don't care about this i'm going to be
asking you a bunch of questions
all right but i want to be able to talk
about this as if you're not staring at
me and as if there's a man i haven't met
named thomas who's standing in the
corner right now
that's a real thing hey thomas before we
go into this
you know why i'm wearing this shirt
today david oh well because it was our
favorite movie
yes when we were like 16 years old i
spent a whole summer at david henry's
house
never changed my clothes the entire time
nope and
all we did was watch anchorman and play
halo
and quote anchorman during his hearing
halo as the insult
my girlfriend has wanted me to throw
this shirt out forever because it's got
holes all over it in the back here and
stuff but i said
not till henry comes over
you leave my shirt alone woman all right
so there's the live event
which uh at the end of this video you
were saying you're gonna have like a q a
afterwards so you do like a watch along
i believe you were telling me before we
filmed the rejects can get a special
discount code right
that's right we're giving it to the
reject so the typical ticket is 11.99
and for
your fans it'll be 9.99 awesome all
right so then i will i will make sure to
participate in this watch along then
excellent because before i had zero
interest
you know it's funny greg so we we had a
theatrical window before kovit so the
plan was to go to theaters
and then when covet hit all that kind of
went down the tubes and we said
you know what let's pivot let's innovate
let's do something live selena's all
behind the film
let's do something that can speak to our
collective fans but also
the world and anyone who needs a
feel-good experience so we created this
live
premiere i've been to so many premieres
and i've been lucky that i've been to
premieres because of
my business and what i do as an actor
but so many people don't get to
experience that so many people don't get
to
sit in a q a after the premiere with the
director and see get his take on things
and get the actors up there and have him
take a bow in front of you so we said
you know what let's do something that
hasn't been done before let's innovate
in covid and let's
bring people that premier experience
nice
and so we wanted to make it even better
so we got charlie and dixie demilio
who charlie's the most followed
tick-tocker in the world they're hosting
the whole thing they were big fans of
wizards waverly place and they loved
this film so we're
we're stoked to try to innovate
something new here but make it
meaningful and it's a benefit so
we're benefiting covet 19 relief oh man
you are a great american david
say i'm not baby who's all going to be
at the at the event is the whole cast so
the whole cast will be there so
basically the run of show
is celine and i will welcome fans right
at the beginning so 4 30 pacific
standard
7 30 eastern the second the movie ends
celine and i will come back on screen to
give closing words
charlie and dixie will come on they'll
introduce me selena and the cast
craig sulkin vanessa morano jake short
um uh lorenzo henry yeah
uh alyssa jarrell's jeff garland will be
there too he's hilarious he's so funny
i'm pretty sure he's just gonna take
over the entire yeah
i've seen a lot of like podcasts and
interviews with the guy he's so just
gonna turn into the
show which i want because he's he's
amazing after the q and a's lovely the
band is going to do a new performance
they're going to play new songs off of
their new album which just came up
just came out um so we're just swallowed
weird
lovely the band will have a performance
afterwards live playing songs on their
new album
and then for the watch long of the fans
being able to interact with
uh all you guys while this event's going
on where's that going to be is it that's
on the website as well yeah we built a
platform so that'll essentially all take
place in one seamless experience on this
is the year dot film all you're gonna
have to do is put your code in after you
purchase your ticket nice
and you just stay in one place the whole
time and it'll all be completely
interactive and built for you no
clicking nothing just you just watch
if you don't notice my question i'm
gonna get pissed off at you
i will look hard and if this video gets
a copyright strike for including your
video
i'm gonna get so upset
me too sorry david video's not public
you gave me a strike man i don't know
what to tell you so you and selena
produced this together she executive
produced it i wrote and directed it you
wrote and directed okay so you really
want to make sure that you get the
credit you deserve
she executive producer i wrote and
directed this okay hold on i'll do it
again ask me the question
ask me the question so you instantly
produce this no no
okay that's some great improv right
there that's so that's what they teach
you at improv
no but what i'm watching from the
trailer here it reminds me of movies
like 500 days of summer oh yeah like
real good feel good movies coming of age
stories so we have the event coming up
but really quick what is the exact plot
of the movie because there's going to be
an official trailer coming out later on
at some point this month but just to
give the audiences an idea what's like
the official plot it's a about a high
school senior named josh who's played by
lorenzo henry going after his
his infatuation she's leaving town with
her boyfriend and he basically lies and
says he has tickets to see
her favorite band at a music festival
and along the way plans on professing
his love to her
however unforeseen circumstances enter
the equation and he starts to question
his desires for that girl and um maybe
there's someone else in the picture
maybe there's someone else maybe there's
a there's a there's a best friend along
for the road trip that uh
makes things very exciting classic um
love triangle
triangley things come into play it's a
writer when you coming out right yeah
yeah exactly love triangle
written by david henry
music and why is this called this is the
year because it seems like it's not
for most of the world right now really
seems like it's not
that's also part of the message we're
trying to get across is we can flip it
on its head
life will always have obstacles
situations difficulties things that are
thrown out at us
and you can always make this your year
so the whole point of this
is to bring a positive feel-good message
to you and to the world and try to
inspire us all
after we watch this movie and have this
you know fun experience with familiar
faces
hopefully all of us can try to do
something to make this your year somehow
work on yourself work on your health
work on your mental health help a friend
reach out to someone in need i hope that
all of us will look back on this year
and go you know what it was a really
crummy situation
but i did something good with it or i
tried to do something good with it
so that's kind of why we wanted to
really embrace that title and try to
flip it on its head
that's beautiful and the good thing you
can do this year is
watch this is the year and you use the
reject code
for sure when david gets sincere i'm
just like where's my joke in that
he's teaming me up i feel it
[Laughter]
also we're having a tick tock challenge
you can win a chance to win a tick tock
with charlie and dixie demilio so pay
attention to that it'll be the hashtag
this is the your challenge on tick tock
charlie dicks will be releasing it
shortly after you see this youtube video
there's one thing people like to do
nowadays it's make a tick tock
and watch a trailer yeah so what was it
like directing lorenzo
was rebellious
he would just say things he would just
say things that you'd only say to a
brother
he'd be like do you really need this
much coverage
[Laughter]
i haven't seen lorenzo in years but i
can totally imagine that
he'd be like why are you getting all
these shots
he's like don't you just get it get a
wide and two close-ups let's move on
i was like why did i make you the lady
lorenzo
i was like no no no that's not what
we're doing
he'd say things like don't you got it
already
no i need another tape but i'm sure his
performance is great he does a great job
i mean it's lorenzo he does a phenomenal
job we're brothers so we have that kind
of
loving banter back of course it's just
when everyone is around listening
is when it got and it got awkward
are you in the movie yourself uh i do a
small role yeah okay
you walk away with the two chicks at the
end yeah you just step into the
it's just mirror with the girls
character's name is sebastian
i picked up on that so with the
direction style that you took with this
i've seen like one of your short films
before
boo no
that one really brought me to tears with
your style with this was the musical
inspirations a big part of
getting a tonal type of absolutely
absolutely yeah i had an entire playlist
uh before we went into the movie that i
would play on set all the time
just to kind of give the tone to
everybody so everyone could feel the
tone i had songs for scenes all sorts of
stuff like that that kind of gave the
pacing rhythm vibe to the actors to
everyone on on the set hopefully could
feel it what we were doing and i had all
that picked out ahead of time i had the
music supervisor on early
so i could build a playlist for all the
actors to have as well studying
that's great i mean with all your acting
experience i'm sure that that actually
came in handy for being a director for
this 100
i tried to learn from like every
director that i ever worked with i tried
to take the best
things from all of them and try to do
that on this film i really appreciated
people who would send like little care
packages before you got on set of like
movie references
character references in movies for that
specific actor
music so everyone had a nice little
email from me ahead of time of homework
before they got to
the set so this is kind of like what
edgar wright did with baby driver before
a feel-good coming of age
amazing and he was my he was my biggest
inspiration for this i literally
i literally wasn't being serious i'm
dead no wow that's crazy now
in a sense i tried to focus because i
don't have anywhere near budgets that he
works with but yeah
i tried to focus on uh seamless
transitions in the film like
like hard transition elements so it
wasn't just like cutting to a wide of a
house and then going in the house you
know i tried to make
i tried to cut into action to keep the
story moving so i referenced a lot of
his
transition shots like from scott pilgrim
not the movie itself but just the
transition
shots so i reference him a lot in terms
of camera work but
content is very different what else do i
ask you david
i don't know i feel like we've covered a
lot but you probably want to ask about
wizards of waverly
i have zero inch well actually i do got
one little comment what's the point of
everyone asking for a reunion when you
guys seem like you got it covered
already
i'm like i'm seeing you and selena here
greg sulkin's in it i just saw you on
greg sulkin's channel
which had uh jennifer stone in it you
guys are taking care of it on your own
why is everyone demanding it
you know you got to get disney's sign
off in order to do the reunion selena
wants to do it we all want to do it
eventually it's just a matter of time
but i think a reunion would be fun a
reunion
uh season where like you know it's it's
it takes place eight years later
i'm so glad you're saying this this is a
great soundbite it's great clickbait for
me
excellent because i i know you haven't
been asked this yet
this is your first time ever having to
answer this question and greg sulkin
i've met this gentleman before
yes he is a gentleman because he's
british extremely handsome no one else
is gentlemanly like him
i become less of a man when i'm around
the guy
me too i just feel that way around most
people from
london yeah i get that impression too
i've never been to london
but anytime i see someone from london on
tv or even putting on an accent
i diminish a little bit as a human being
yeah me too
anyways this is a great great video
we're doing it so
you have this actress from switch that
birth and who's this other person switch
at birth is
vanessa murano and then alyssa girls is
kind of a newcomer this is her first
lead in the film
she was so phenomenal such a team player
so much talent
and she she crushed it she really did
crush it we're kind of purposely trying
to flip the old trope
of the you should go after one type of
girl and it's this hot blonde girl
her whole character was to try to flip
that trope on its head and you'll see it
in the film but
my female rider that i worked with santa
acqualini was very aware of trying to
flip a lot of tropes from 80s films on
their head
in this so it it has a classic 80s feel
to it the movie it's contemporary but
flips a lot of those tropes on its head
and it has a very
empowering message for females which is
what selena gomez really loved and why i
think ultimately she came on board of
the film
is she loved the way uh both girls arcs
in the film were solid and empowering
and had authentic female friendship a
lot of times girls are catty and films
as you know right
and um that's not cool so we didn't do
that
yeah empowerment i love it so it's got
like these genre blends
some classic homage throwback vibes
which are also doing some like genre
deconstruction simultaneously
that was the most elegant sentence i've
ever heard in my life yeah that's the
most elegant sentence i've ever said
as was coming out of my mouth i was like
i'm doing it i'm pulling it off
you said it's so serious yeah so serious
so what you're saying
is genre deconstruction and then genre
mashups so when did you start writing
this and like
how long did it take you to write this
you know it was this movie that taught
me i didn't want to be a writer
even though i do do it i'm actually
writing a netflix show right now
but um it's uh writing's hard
this thing took me like two years three
years to write oh my goodness
it just went through so many iterations
and so many things and it's so easy to
get caught
in doing 52 card pick up you build it up
and then you go oh there's this flaw
here on the plot
that causes you to take down the whole
thing as opposed to like try to patch
that up and keep going so this film was
really my coming of age in writing
ultimately yeah it took about three
years to write not every single day of
of
of writing it was it was in and out and
you know multitasking is that why that
wizard's reunion hasn't happened
yeah we were tried by fire and i really
felt like we got
the best version by the very end and i'm
i'm so proud of what we ended up writing
and ended up bringing to the screen
because it really is uh something i
think i think special and meaningful and
hopefully will be meaningful to people
who watch it
i mean i'm looking at the this footage
that you have here it's independently
produced
but the budget looks pretty damn good
you got this like concert moment
that looks like it got some money to put
together well dude the biggest thing was
uh storyboarding and that was something
i studied from edgar wright is he
storyboards everything so
with the crowd stuff i just tweeted and
people showed up
wow and they weren't being they weren't
being paid to be there but
400 people showed up for our thing they
weren't being paid to be there so they
never had to stay so i only knew i
probably have an hour with these people
before they go get bored and leave
right right so i planned all the big
shots the crowd stuff
the second they got there the shots got
smaller and smaller purposefully as the
day went on because sure enough people
started
and then i had to order like 80 pizzas
to get them to stay for like one more
shot and they did but we barely pulled
it off
that's so funny is that it's the shot i
know that's what i'm like look at the
bunch
i'm off screen with a piece of pizza
it's tossing hot
pizza no i'm very appreciative of
everyone who showed up in alabama
thank you all of you i love you thank
you for showing up on that day you
really made the shot work thank you it
impressed him
all right well david thank you for
coming over thomas thanks for being here
you wanted to say hi thomas hi
[Laughter]
so subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell david thanks for
being here
august 28th what website is that again
this is the your dot film
go watch it there thank you again so
much buddies great seeing you again
stay you stay classy reject nationwide
thomas thomas
you